[Applaudissements]
bonjour bienvenue dans la roulotte de 9
à nizas alors si vous nous regardez
c'est que vous êtes dépressif ou chômage
voulaient dos alors j'en profite pour
saluer ton nous téléspectateurs
bernard martin éric et c'est tout de
suite en preniez téléspectateurs en
ligne il s'agit de civils nous à tête de
meulan en 317 voix l'a eu
bonjour situer votre question voilà je
vous appelle car je suis très inquiet
j'ai perdu ma petite chatte saucisses je
voulais savoir si j'ai une chance de la
voir revenir ce matin là nous assistons
étonné à un cours du professeur
jean-marc la merde on a commencé avec le
premier promu qui doit la danseuse là
moi toi qui d'autre merci trois airs et
peut-être ma troupe du trou maintenant
je peux pas et tout va bien pour moi
c'est facile comme ça nrj 12 trous du
christ à gauche je marque je vois pas
bien le tableau d'ici là quoi mais très
vite mon travail c'est de comprendre et
de soigner les bouffées de chaleur les
roses ni gastrique générés par un air vo
vite et en tractant sur le larynx à
cause d'une dilatation des muqueuses et
du corps spongieux et en d'autres termes
un notation et n'doye de merde allez
monsieur on reprend c'est la dernière
tentative après celle opération alors
visualiser vos cordes vocales à la
respirer maintenant imaginez celle de
gary wright et aux mille ha ouais j'ai
mal un magot c'est mal à ma gorge